how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and everything
relating to the marvel cinematic
universe yesterday a whole bunch of tv
spots came out for spider-man no way
home including a very long trailer type
of tv spot longer than a tv spot but not
quite as long as a full length trailer
but about a minute trailer came out
yesterday as well that everybody is
calling trailer three but with all of
these tv spots and this trailer coming
out yesterday there is just a ton of new
footage that was revealed that we need
to break down including a lot better
looks at some villains and some scenes
that offer us even further hints that
toby maguire spider-man and andrew
garfield spider-man are indeed going to
be in the film which i i think everybody
now kind of believes that and if you
don't no worries either way we will all
see in less than a month now also still
doing our spider-man collectible
giveaway it ends at the end of this
month all you got to do to enter
subscribe to my channel and cosmic
culture and leave some comments on some
recent videos now the first clip we're
going to talk about is with tom hollands
peter parker and ned and mj peter is
saying that i'll fix this which we'll
briefly talk about this is sort of all
his fault all the villains getting out
and terrorizing and destroying new york
that's peter's fault because doctor
strange had them all contained at this
point in time we know from trailers tv
spots and some plot leaks that this cube
that we see in some of these tv spots
and trailers is a key to sending all of
the villains back this is how dr strange
traps them and this is how they're going
to get them back to their own universes
but in the beginning of the movie peter
parker is going to learn that all of
these villains die at the hands of their
respective spider-mans which of course
is toby maguire and andrew garfield
doctor strange says it's the only way
they have to go back which means they'll
probably die peter doesn't really feel
too good about this so he ends up taking
the cube from doctor strange and then
the two of them end up fighting which we
have seen in many tv spots and trailers
at this point in time peter taking the
cube from doctor strange and the two of
them fighting leads to the villains
escaping which in turn is peter's fault
so in this scene that's why he is saying
i'll fix this but even more interesting
is that he goes on to say that he's
going to need some help
i'll fix this but i'm going to need some
help let's catch some multiverse men now
this is referring to one of two things
one it could be the fact that he is
referring to ned and mj we do see them
in the sanctum in the next scene and ned
even says let's catch some multiverse
men and mj says just run at bias next
time before you decide to break the
universe so he could be referring to ned
and mj when he says this and something
that's very interesting about this scene
is that doctor strange has already done
his spell but ned and mj seem to
remember that he is spider-man now
doctor strange said that he did botch
the spell so he messed it up so perhaps
not everybody forgot or perhaps doctor
strange did something to make them
remember but either way at least
throughout the movie mj and ned are
going to remember that peter parker is
spider-man who knows what will happen at
the end of the film though so we could
be talking about ned and mj but he also
could be talking about other spider-men
peter parker our peter parker is
learning that these other spider-men
actually killed and defeated these
villains before so now he has to face
these villains and judging by the
trailers and tv spots at first he's
going to have a pretty hard time so it
would only make sense that at some point
in time he would think to himself well
maybe the other spider-man who have
already defeated these villains maybe we
can bring them into our universe and
they could help defeat these villains
and everybody goes back to their
respective universes even if the other
two spider-men weren't in the film which
they are but even if they weren't this
still has to be a thought of peter
parker these villains come into his
universe that he's never met before they
all think that they know him but then he
realizes that they're thinking about the
peter parker from their universe their
spider-man so he realizes that there are
other spider-man out there and even in
this little trailer that we got
yesterday we have a scene of peter
parker saying the multiverse is real
realizing everything then we have this
awesome new footage of doc ock and
spidey fighting of course on the
infamous bridge but doc ock appears and
says hello peter and peter replies do i
know you in which he immediately starts
to get his butt kicked by doc ock dock
grabs him with his arms wraps him up
brings him forward and says you think
your fancy new suit is gonna save you
then after this scene is where he still
has peter parker grabbed and he gets him
without his mask on and he realizes that
he is not the same peter parker from his
universe and says you're not peter so in
this scene he realizes that not only is
this a new spider-man suit but it's a
new spider-man altogether now we've seen
some footage from the scene that shows
the two of them fighting doc ock is
throwing a lot of things up peter and it
looks like he might even throw a vehicle
at him maybe a van or a bus as we see
peter break through the roof of it with
his iron spider legs and here we kind of
have a funny moment doc ock obviously
has his four tentacle arms in which now
peter parker in the iron spider suit now
has four spider-man legs and doc makes
the joke to his arm saying looks like we
got competition which is great to see
because of course it's a marvel movie
it's going to be funny now this is a
more serious movie with the multiverse
breaking out and all of the villains
coming but we're going to have some
awesome funny moments of course as well
i mean it is still spider-man and we get
an awesome new look at a couple of
villains as well we get a brand new look
at electro and he is wearing something
that looks oddly familiar if you take a
look at his right shoulder to our left
he is definitely wearing an arc reactor
it is literally identical it looks just
like the triangular arc reactor that
iron man had in iron man 2. and this
raises a lot of questions like how did
electro get this when did he get this
because he definitely did not have this
at the end of the amazing spider-man 2.
and the last time that we saw him he
died either that or he got transported
somewhere else but i'm gonna go ahead
and say he died since that's kind of
what doctor strange is saying in the tv
spots so does that mean that he got to
this universe and somehow got his hands
on an arc reactor that part right now is
unclear but this actually probably
answers a very good question that we've
all been having about elektron that is
why isn't he blue anymore not that
anyone's complaining because he looks a
lot better now but why the change why is
he all of a sudden a normal looking
person who can shoot electricity with a
device on him well the arc reactor would
solve that question it looks like he is
using the arc reactor to harness all of
the energy that is inside of him all of
the electricity that could be the reason
for the new suit the arc reactor
harnesses all the electricity and it
allows him to release it in concentrated
blast and it also allows him to not be
blue anymore because we do actually have
one scene where spider-man is wearing
his black and gold suit he does have
magic around his arms and in the
background we can actually see electro
and he's still kind of the old electro
he's still blue so at some point in time
in our universe he is going to stumble
upon this arc reactor perhaps i'll even
break into stark industries i'm
definitely excited to see how this plays
out and this is definitely something
that has my attention i think it's
really cool that he's using an arc
reactor to do this but the big question
is how exactly did he get a hold of it
and most importantly it does still seem
like we are going to get at least talk
of iron man and spider-man no way home
which does make sense considering that
far from home did talk about iron man a
lot they had murals of him on the walls
and this takes place immediately after
far from home so basically the same time
now last but not least we do get two
very good looks at sandman and the
lizard they're brief but they're good
one we have the lizard just screaming
but it's the best look that we have of
him so far and the new look that we have
of sandman actually shows him catching
spider-man in his hand and we get a lot
better look of how he's actually going
to be when he fights cgi has come a very
long way since spider-man 3 and it's
awesome to see and these are the new
scenes that the trailer and tv spot have
shown us a lot of new footage which is
awesome because i didn't think we were
going to get much more until the end but
let me know what you think about all of
this new footage all of these new tv
spots in the comments down below don't
forget to like the video and of course
for live updates you can find me on
instagram twitter or tiktok and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you